Monica is pretty personal for you this
film is pretty personal right oh yeah I
mean every trans story is personal for
me um Monica I mean there's so many
Monas out there I feel like our journey
uh with with our families and just where
we fall in the world and how the world
makes space for us or doesn't make space
for us is always going to be a fight
that we're going to have to fight at
least in my lifetime probably um but
this movie it you know it's it's for the
girls it's for dolls it's for the fem
Queens it's for the trans women
that I've been waiting for so long for
their stories to be told it centers on
her it's not centered on someone else
it's it's through her lens which is very
different usually you know if there's a
trans person involved in a movie they're
they're not the protagonist they're not
the centerpiece um so that's why this
film is so special but that's why I I
said yes faster to this film than any
film I've ever done in my very long
career yeah because it was it kind of
still very emotional for me it was not
lost on me Kelly that that it would give
an extraordinary transgender actress the
lead I said I'll be your backup singer
any day I knew how important this film
was yeah what Monica does is deeply
humanizes a trans woman at the center of
a story we are human beings deserving of
Love deserving rights and respect and
it's really about a rehumanizing process
that has to happen in relationship to
trans people and great storytelling is a
beautiful way to do
[Music]
[Applause]
that thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home